My biggest problem with reading is I don't understand what I'm reading.
It makes me feel like I'm dumb when I can't do what everybody else can do.
She was spending too much time deciphering...
...word by word versus understanding what she was reading,...
...and in eight months, now she can read and understand a full paragraph.
The SDSU reading program is providing a very beneficial resource...
...to not only the City Heights community but the San Diego community.
We assess each child and based upon the assessments,...
...we design instruction that's entirely tailored to that child's need.
It works.
The students and the parents, they see results,...
...huge gains in just a few months, and so for them, this is a godsend.
Confident. That's my favorite word I've learned.
I learned that here,...
...and I know I'm gonna get to sixth grade level by the time I get into sixth grade.
I'm not giving up anytime soon.